diese Politik der 1000 nadelschiche ist
gescheitert so das muss man eben sagen
das sehen wir anhand der Bilder die wir
hier gesehen haben es reicht eben nicht
jeden Tag in der Shisha in der Shisha
Bar Razzia zu machen und vor den Augen
der Öffentlichkeit sozusagen zu
präsentieren wir tun jetzt was wir tun
jetzt was ist richtig aber vor vielen
Jahren ist schon aufgeschrieben worden
ich war selber Teil einer ruhekonferenz
habe da mitgemacht und da ist
aufgeschrieben worden dass man nur für
die Probleme im Ruhrgebiet eine
dreistellige Anzahl von Ermittlerinnen
und Ermittlern benötigt wie viel hat es
tatsächlich in NRW gegeben 20 also 20
zusätzliche Stellen auch so das heißt
wir wenn wir darüber reden was ist
eigentlich zu tun dann sind die Dinge
auch schon lange aufgeschrieben worden
das wird es reicht eben nicht mit
Überschriften zu arbeiten sondern es
müssen hinterher Menschen machen weil
die Straftätern jetzt rede ich mal nur
über die Straftäter und rede da
gruppierungsübergreifen sind ja mehrere
tausend über die wir gerade reden und da
müssen natürlich im mittleren und
Ermittler mit einem breiten
Erfahrungshorizont zusammenkommen um
diese Strukturen aufzuhellen
[Musik]